[Música]
ahora por la mañana que venía hacia acá
me cayó en las manos una noticia de la
bbc
en donde dice que este año de
coronavirus
significará en el avance de las mujeres
25 años de retroceso
qué es lo que está en el centro de este
señalamiento lo que está en el centro de
este señalamiento es que las mujeres
desde siempre desde hace más o menos
cinco o seis mil años hemos tenido en
nuestras manos y sobre nuestros hombros
llevándolo en solitario sin que nadie lo
vea nadie lo reconozca
nadie lo pague todo el trabajo de los
cuidados esos trabajos domésticos no
remunerados esos trabajos que hacen
posible la vida
porque si hay un
trabajo humano entre los humanos ese es
el trabajo de los cuidados
y esto atraviesa la vida de todas las
mujeres
en nuestro país y sé de lo que hablo
cuando asumí la responsabilidad de
trabajar en el instituto nacional de las
mujeres durante el primer año recorrí el
país
desde allá desde upala hasta grano de
oro en turrialba
regresando al paso del indio allá por
corredores y yéndonos luego a la alegría
de sarapiquí y luego subíamos a la
historia de sixaola en talamanca
distintas mujeres con distintas vidas
con distintos reclamos ante la vida con
distintos dolores y distintas alegrías
pero todas absolutamente
todas
sabiendo lo que significa tener el peso
de los cuidados sobre los hombros y qué
es lo que eso ha significado para las
mujeres y por qué hoy la bbc
prende alarmas diciéndonos cuidado que
estamos retrocediendo un cuarto de siglo
ante esta pandemia
porque los niños y las niñas han
regresado a las casas y siempre hay una
mirada femenina viendo si estuvo la
tarea si el niño no se fue en un hueco
si ya se le sacó el jugo de naranja y
por qué las personas con algún grado de
dependencia
hoy están mucho más necesitadas de
cuidados y ahí estamos las mujeres ahí
estamos las mujeres eso es de lo que
alerta a la bbc y eso es lo que recorre
la preocupación de las mujeres que en
este país sabemos cuáles son las
necesidades
que cuáles son los obstáculos que
tenemos que vencer para poder decir un
día ojalá muy pronto
que tenemos los mismos derechos
que nuestros hermanos y compañeros
varones ya que me refiero que es lo que
interrumpe llevar la carga de los
cuidados sobre los hombros en solitario
interrumpe nuestras posibilidades de
capacitarnos
conseguir trabajos formales hoy el país
según el instituto nacional de
estadística y censos dice que la tasa
neta de participación laboral de las
mujeres en el mundo del trabajo formal
ha retrocedido 30 años porque tenemos
que estar en la casa viendo a los niños
a las niñas a los ancianos a los
familiares cuidando de que ahí no pase
nada porque la pandemia ha puesto en el
centro de la atención
precisamente la enorme trascendencia de
los cuidados no es la productividad lo
que ha estado en el centro en ocho meses
en las conferencias de prensa del
ministro de salud
no ha puesto ahí la atención don daniel
sales salas él ha puesto en la necesidad
de que aprendamos a cuidarnos de eso que
las mujeres sabemos y qué es lo que
compartimos todas en este país más allá
de nuestras diferencias
precisamente saber cuál es el peso que
se tiene en nuestras vidas como nos ha
impedido
hacernos valer en el mundo público y
hemos tenido que respetar el mandato
histórico de que a las mujeres lo que
nos corresponden son los espacios
domésticos estos espacios chiquitos
intrascendentes
lo importante lo de afuera lo de puertas
afuera eso le corresponde a los varones
ellos cuidan la civilización lo
importante y las mujeres lo
intrascendente
abrir esa puerta y salir al mundo de lo
público ha costado décadas eso es lo que
señala la bbc y eso es lo que hemos
tenido en mente y como preocupación las
mujeres y quizás esa fue la razón
principal por la que un día me decidí a
asumir una responsabilidad dentro del
inamu
precisamente
para trabajar por lo que se llama la
corresponsabilidad social de los
cuidados y no es únicamente la
repartición justa dentro de un núcleo
familiar por lo que peleamos no también
peleamos por la obligación de emitir
políticas públicas que le permitan a las
mujeres
poder poner el pie fuera de la casa
fuera del espacio doméstico y sentir que
el mundo le brinda
exactamente las mismas oportunidades que
a los varones no pedimos ni una
oportunidad más lo único que estamos
pidiendo es igualdad
es poder nosotras
dedicar horas que hoy se nos van porque
ahí se nos va la vida en los cuidados
dedicar horas
para poder prepararnos y también
encargarnos de eso importantísimo que es
el cuido de la civilización no vamos a
abandonar en ningún trabajo otro ese que
lo hacemos desde el alma
y con unas manos que saben que si se
cansan habrán otras mujeres que las
sustituyan y que sigan sosteniendo al
mundo en sus manos pero vamos a exigir
como mujeres lúcidas y generosas vamos a
exigir para las más jóvenes que se abran
los caminos y que efectivamente
y haya unas medidas que aseguren la
corresponsabilidad social de los
cuidados es ahí donde hacia dónde nos
dirigimos y cuando esto se consiga y
conforme avancemos
esa dependencia económica porque resulta
que nadie le ha puesto jamás precio a lo
que las mujeres
aportamos a la economía hasta que hace
un año el banco central y el inamu no
nos dedicamos a la tarea con los datos
que nos dio la última encuesta del uso
del tiempo
que que nos dio los números de que las
mujeres semanalmente
le entregamos a los trabajos de cuidados
un poco más de 35 horas mientras que los
varones 13 esos son los promedios con
estos datos en la mano el banco central
le puso un valor monetario a lo que las
mujeres hacemos y el resultado es que
las mujeres con ese trabajo de cuidados
y doméstico no remunerado
le entregamos al país un
25.3 por ciento del pib si se nos pagará
eso es lo que hay que reivindicar
esa llamada economía de los cuidados y
en ese marco vamos a caminar
teniendo como norte
indudable que debemos de asegurarle a
las futuras generaciones sobre todo pero
a las actuales también que poner los
pies en los espacios públicos es nuestro
derecho y que para hacerlo en igualdad
de condiciones
necesitamos que las responsabilidades de
los cuidados sean compartidas con los
núcleos familiares y con el estado que
nos provea de las redes de cuidados
necesarias para conseguirlo
[Música]